uh the ufc
has mastered the live show
so good
unbelievable and what i mean by that is
here's the perfect example how you've
been to a boxing match before yeah live
fight yeah
let's say you're going to floyd
mayweather fight
when did the famous people come oh right
before the main event yeah
this is what i was looking at when i was
there i was like when are the famous
people going to get in here and sit down
because famous people for boxing matches
they just come for floyd they just come
maybe for the last two if the last two
are big fights but rarely but they want
everybody to see them coming in exactly
they want to see them you're wearing the
crazy outfits etc you get caught the
famous people here for the entire main
card
not just the last two fights probably
the last like four fights yeah or five
fights mike tyson tyson dwyane wade
dwyane wade
they had the elk boys in there they had
johnny knoxville mark wahlberg
i mean it was all of them were there
this whole section for them is there and
it's [ __ ] ram packed for the whole
main card
and i'm looking around
and we were all talking we're like what
is going on here there wasn't a second
of distraction they had light show going
on they had music constantly the music
was good it wasn't [ __ ] like you
felt like you were at a concert i think
they had a dj like a live dj oh it was
in the back yeah okay that makes sense
now he didn't have a booth where you saw
him but he was paying attention enough
to like the people that he was
entertaining
and the whole experience was [ __ ]
unreal and i'm looking at this and i'm
like this is what you get when you have
one institution controlling it back in
the day
when the fights were on uh hbo or
showtime there was different promoters
that would end up doing those fights
sometimes it was promoted at don king
sometimes it was bob arum and they were
in partnership with hbo but it's harder
to be consistent in the production you
put out
if you don't know what that producer
wants to cough up for that production
when you are the ufc you control every
dollar coming in and out and they have
invested in making that live show at
[ __ ] unbelievably
and
i mean it was just so good dude it was
just so good through and through as
someone who performs live for a living i
look at other live performances and i'm
like how are they going to keep these
people entertained it was amazing
like you didn't want dude watching a
basketball game sucks compared to it
sucks
like i can't wait to leave and get a
drink or something when i'm watching a
basketball game as long as it's not the
fourth quarter yeah this is boring like
whatever like unless it's a superheated
playoff game or something this was
non-stop distraction stimulus and it was
the best live event in the fight game
that i've seen it's funny you say that
because even watching i had to tape the
game because i was editing this weekend
the playoff games even watching i was
like let's just fast forward to the
[ __ ] fourth goal let's just go and
football is masterful and i'm 30 seconds
ahead every okay there's a play let's go
i don't hear commentary and football
yeah it's the most exciting to watch on
tv you red zoned it yourself yeah i was
like let's just get to yeah and the
games were [ __ ] amazing yeah but i
was like it's two quarters do i really
need to watch the first half
yeah and ufc you're gonna sit for the
whole thing and i was curious as you
were talking
what would mike tyson say about a ufc
live event versus a boxing life
interesting i would actually like to
hear
as a [ __ ] boxing fanatic that he is
yeah is he still more entertained by ufc
if so why yeah that's a great question i
don't know we got to get him on and ask
him i don't know again outsider i think
ufc it seems like they do a great job of
hyping up the undercards that were good
fights and i think boxing tries but ufc
seems to successfully do it but it's
hard because you're not as uh invested
in those people because you might not
promote them and oftentimes with boxing
it's two promoters working together so
each promoter has this this list of
fighters neither one of them wants to
see them lose because one loss in boxing
is the equivalent of like 10 losses in
ufc right so it's like why would they
work together to make sure it's a good
fight so then the other person that you
get is some tomato can that your guy can
beat up and that's boring every one of
these ufc fights is competitive right
they know if they put on a good showing
that they'll be back out there and the
ufc has invested in promoting every
single one of their fighters that they
have under contract yeah and even if you
lose if you fight your ass off you're
valiant then we'll you'll watch you
it'll be like a win it'll be an
emotional win 100 huh i dude it was
yeah i mean what did you think mark yeah
i mean insane like you're captivated the
whole time we were there for what four
or five hours yeah and there's only like
an hour of action yep like all together
between all the fights and all the
rounds yeah so it has like this really
great capability of like you're sitting
there kind of like you can't kind of
hang in between yeah like there's
something to watch so you don't have to
necessarily talk you can like network
yeah and then the fight starts and it's
just locked in yeah watching the most
intense like intense like melee yeah and
then it just breaks up throughout the
night it's really awesome and then the
fans in anaheim specifically were great
listen
if it's a
professional
fight that doesn't have mexicans
don't even go
after you're in an arena full of mexican
fans dude this is what what like soccer
fans must get in europe like that kind
of like love connectivity in south
america you like that maybe the most
insane fan base of any sport ever the
best so much [ __ ] love so much
passive way you can't do it there's one
of the fighter's names with brandon
moreno so an entire arena full of
mexicans is screaming let's go brandon
right and it's just the only time that
that happens there's zero politics
involved like
it was just like
the energy was [ __ ] unreal man you
need you need mexicans or like a
culturally instinct group of people that
is just so [ __ ]
fervent as a fan yeah uh it's like a fan
base for a fight i'm sure like filipinos
are the same way with manny pacquiao or
like puerto ricans when it was boxing
but like that just makes it so much more
special right like
speaking of that like um how would you
compare it to the lucha
libre oh interesting
yeah yeah entertaining the whole way
through yeah yeah yeah a similar vibe
but like there's just way higher stakes
yes you know like you watched libre like
just being able to sit back in your
chair like oh wow this is funny lucha
libre for everybody's listening that is
the uh like wwe but in mexico yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
we went for andrew's bachelor parties
one event i didn't leave early but yeah
that that is great
oh yeah
i didn't leave early oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah
but you watch it and it's like oh yeah i
get to sit back and enjoy like this
almost like soap opera type thing yeah
it's like a tv novella but then if you
go to ufc fights like you can't look
away i don't even know anyone yeah it's
literally lucha libre
if
they could become bloody and unconscious
yeah like lucha libre has unscripted
yeah it's unscripted it's like lucha
libre has to do these like really cool
uh theatrical stunts yeah
they have choreographed pieces yeah
exactly wrestling match it's dance in a
lot of ways like this crazy gymnastics
and we would get really excited i think
based on the level of difficulty of
those tricks and that's the stakes and
those are the things people have
famously died like la parka died doing a
stunt in an actual match oh i didn't
know that jesus christ pretty sure holy
[ __ ] and so that's the stakes you're
watching for exactly and now those
stakes are baked into every interaction
yeah but it's just they [ __ ] get it
dude and it was one of those things
where like like mark and i are sitting
there watching it and like all we're
thinking is like oh how can we
incorporate this into
how can we make our shows as
entertaining through and through
you know what can we and dude one of the
coolest things i'm hyped right now on
this but one of the coolest things is
really interesting we're sitting we're
watching it right how are the seats
phenomenal they did a great job they did
a great job and um
we're sitting we're watching it and uh
we look left now if you're watching the
octagon right here
we look left and there's the the door to
leave the arena right and through the
door
you see
an ambulance it is the first thing
outside the door
and it's not left there like
intentionally like scare people watching
of course it just so happened that it
was right there when we looked over but
it's this beautiful reminder of the
carnage
that exists in the ring like and the
stakes in the stakes it's like this is
so dangerous the ambulance needs to be
right outside the door right because if
something bad happens every second
counts right and i think they should do
that [ __ ] on purpose
yeah like it's just beautiful reminder
like this [ __ ] in a game yeah like you
think it's a game everybody's talking
all that [ __ ] you think it's wwe there's
a [ __ ] ambulance there yeah and
somebody's leaving a stretcher my
favorite part of the fight was that
wasn't any of the fighters wasn't any
like anything that happened in the
octagon it was that one person had a
better seat than you oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah shout out to [ __ ] shane gillis
man
[ __ ] made me so happy yeah yeah yeah
dude
i hope he talks about it on his podcast
but it was so funny so we listen i
rolled i've rolled deep
yeah
you know what i'm saying i roll deep no
matter what because
i am very grateful like you know where i
am in this business as a product of
everybody's work right so i want
everybody to experience these things
right um
and but i was so [ __ ] tight so i told
joe right i told i told rogan i was like
yo we're going to to the fight we'll see
you there he goes yo do you need me to
get you uh seats and i was like
the ufc reached out and they wanted to
get seats and i don't want to you know i
don't want to what is it like bite the
hand that feeds you that kind of thing
disrespectful yeah we'll be disappointed
that was really nice for them to offer
seats you know what i mean and we're
coming through five people so it's nice
to put up but then i hit him i was like
i mean but do you think yours are gonna
be better
right now what he says to me is i'm sure
they'll be in the same area and i was
like okay cool so you can't question
that even if that sounds like there's
gonna be better seats than mine you
can't be like yeah but are they gonna be
better than my specific girls then you
seem like a dick bro yeah i
we go we they give us five seats i we
have two on the floor right right and
then there's three up on the uh like
perfect it's like section 208 but it's
actually like the middle it's like
center court
if you're the basketball court and
looking right in the ring it's awesome
objectively better seat at 2008 yeah it
was like i went and watched a few fights
with you guys there and i was like this
is a much better viewing line it's right
behind like all the vip people like all
the announcers you're looking at johnny
knoxville's head you're looking at
tyson's head you're looking at everybody
coming it was [ __ ] on the floor we
were looking up half the time at the
screens at the screen yeah it is just
because of the angle and everything now
the energy on the floor is really cool
you're walking right up to the gate
you're saying hi to bruce buffer right
at the gate you know rogue in dc they're
right there you say what's up it's just
it's awesome but i saw [ __ ] shane i'm
like this [ __ ] shane is like
basically coaching the fighters
like shane could spit into the ring from
his chair 100 like if he if he laughed
hard drinking a bud light he would spit
the blood light on the fighters 100
right and i didn't know where he was i
was like because rogan said he was there
i was like yo where are you and then i
just saw his dumb head [ __ ] pop up
this literally pops up from like right
behind one of the cameras like he's so
close yeah he's so close and i was like
this [ __ ] dude i should have
cooking the goddamn tickets from joe
i woke up to go say hi i go up i'm like
oh come to the banister i walk up he
walks over and a security guard goes sir
you can't bother the people on this side
bro shade we all kind of furious shane's
wearing like a hoodie and like a
pennsylvania shipping solution
like literally like he looks like he's
there to fix the ring
the fence broke a little bit dude it was
so funny and i hope he talks about this
on his pot but like the night before he
got to hang out with nate diaz and his
boys like they just went out oh
i hope he talks about he'll probably fit
in perfectly bro the stories are
hilarious the stories are [ __ ]
hilarious but uh i hope he talks about
and then we went and grabbed some dinner
afterwards that was fun and then i drank
too much red wine and i just uh
violently vomited at an airport bathroom
for [ __ ] yeah what's that all i know
is we're trying to set up a zoom call to
meet about what we're going to talk
about today and then andrew goes i just
threw up everywhere in the airport
bathroom and then he i talked to him an
hour later and he's like yeah there's
literally vomit coming out of the sides
of the stall into the other stalls
[ __ ] red
out of the elevator it really was it was
pure red a little bit of broccoli
projectile vomiting right and i
understand why people like put their
face right over the toilet because like
i was vomiting from a standing position
so it was just going everywhere did you
think it was gonna happen
i don't know i have a penis i peed
directly in it but it came out like a
girl's [ __ ] like it was just like how
girls pee it just splattered everywhere
i saw both shoes on either sides
of the stalls next to me
sea walk out of the way
100
i was vomiting all over both of their
feet and the beautiful thing about
throwing up on someone is they can't
attack you
because they'll just get even more throw
up on it yeah yeah yeah yeah so i just
stood there [ __ ] thrown up
i ate yeah i ate some bread vala got me
a bagel and uh and some toast and i and
i and i rallied and i got on that flight
right and yeah then you took a six hour
flight and then i took a six hour flight
that was before the hood right before
the flight [ __ ] yeah absolutely
beautiful
yeah oh yeah i was absolutely brutal
yeah what was the fight of the night by
the way
the actual fight night or or our pick
our pick right yeah yeah yeah yeah uh i
am curious about francis too because
he's a homie and i heard he wasn't
supposed to win and he won yeah the
francis gone fight was really i wasn't i
just read twitter and then people were
like oh he won and i was like okay yeah
he won i thought he won on points uh i
thought gone was really good but what
francis did
and i didn't realize this is that he had
this element but he basically just took
him down like he was getting outstruck
and then he just said i'm bigger than
you yeah i did not exceed like oh yeah
francis is gonna wrestle the wrestler
like don has a wrestling like uh martial
arts background yeah i think uh he would
do like muay thai yeah he had like muay
thai fights and actually like if i'm
going to the ground i don't want to go
to the ground with this guy yeah francis
goes i don't care
and just leans on him leans on him and
just i mean it was really it was really
interesting to see him switch that gear
and it was funny because like the day
before there's a video came out with a
dc
you know dc yeah cormier and uh
daniel cormier is like always teasing
the fighters when he's always like
pretends to wrestle like he's like a
real gym dude you can tell you know it's
like you ever go to the boxing gym and a
guy starts like shadow boxing for you
like that's just their communication uh
skills or whatever and he did that and
then francis kind of like blocked the
takedown and france and uh dc is like oh
he's a wrestler now he's a wrestler now
and then literally the next day
wrestling is what wins him that [ __ ]
huh and this is an interesting thing
because he's the ufc champ without any
contract to fight anymore
yeah it's fascinating so we could see
the ufc not renew his contract and then
a ufc champ gets stripped of their title
for nothing more than not being able to
have more
uh fights on a contract yeah so he
technically didn't really lose it in the
ring hmm so even if he's not fighting
anymore that's still the real ufc champ
wow and he wants to box
yeah
he wants it he wants the big money
fighter tyson fury and
and of course the ufc is going i don't
want to let my fighters be able to just
go box whenever they want because if i
give them that contract then they're all
going to ask for the same thing right
now i'm sure just like what happened
with floyd uh you know and conor i'm
sure if they made a big money fight and
the ufc got a piece of that a
significant piece which is what happened
with conor
that they could work something out
but there was a lot of stakes on this
fight he loses he has no negotiation
leverage gone oh [ __ ] yeah but he did
the damn thing he did the [ __ ] damn
he is like i mean he's just gotta be
pound for pound like the baddest man on
the planet
undeniable right like insane power size
reach
like fight iq was good yeah like
bought with a torn mcl completely oh
yeah and strange acl happened a few
weeks ago and he's like i don't want to
pull out of the fight and i noticed i
saw him wearing these like knee yeah and
i thought someone was really smart if
you hurt one of your knees yeah
yeah
if you hurt one of your knees
and you put a knee brace on just one oh
that guy's gonna go after that knee i'm
attacking that knee if you hurt one of
your knees and put them on both i'm
going ah yeah maybe his knees are sore
from training but there's not actual
significant damage to one of them and
even then you might forget even during
the fight which one it is [ __ ] so i
thought that was a pretty smart tactic
what a hostage right yeah and it was
insane watching that fight directly
after brandon moreno yeah like going
from super heavyweight biggest guys in
the [ __ ] you know institution to like
the small or from the smallest guys to
the base guys yeah like seeing the fight
style change completely yeah yeah
interesting yeah it was just it was
great it was it was a lot of fun
and i'm curious to see what happens i
hope that he's able to fight tyson fury
yeah i think a knockout would have
really propelled that fight further
but
i mean i just i would love to die
does he have any chance against tyson
fury boxing
i want to say no the one didn't you call
tyson fury the greatest heavyweight ever
i think
and francis and ghana is going to tweet
you've never seen france in ghana
fighting i've also never seen francis
and god of fights okay
you know it was interesting benue yeah
had an interesting story our buddy ben
we talk about on this podcast a lot we
love ben uh he came with us and he
posted on a story of the seven billion
people on the planet
these two guys are the best at fighting
that's crazy or like the most dominant
fight or something like that like can
beat up every those two guys in the ring
that we saw of all the human beings on
the planet can [ __ ] up
the most people every single one now
that's pretty crazy was saying he's
gonna put jon jones in there but we
don't know jon jones has never fought a
heavyweight he says jon jones could take
both of them he he says it but so far
we don't know and like we saw with
like we saw with izzy when he went up
and wait
and fought yawn and like we've seen so
many times when boxers go up and wait it
is difficult yeah it is very it doesn't
matter how incredibly technically
nobody's more technically skilled than
is he yeah but there's a certain point
in time where 40 pounds that's exactly
what you said francis did to
uh go on that
that's what happened to izzy the guy
just leaned on him 40 pounds is 40
pounds bro yeah
yeah but it was it was pretty if jon
jones came back
would francis not go box and would he be
like all right here's the super fight i
can make my money here i think the big
money fight is tyson fury and i hope
that they work it out it'll just be fun
for the fans i think the thing that they
need to do is make sure it's less rounds
eight rounds
you know what i'm saying 12 is crazy 12
is crazy 12 is is that's not even gonna
be fun
eight rounds of heavyweights even if one
of them can't fight there's [ __ ]
slugging each other that'd be fun i
think that that's what we might see i
think when you when there's less rounds
you have uh far more uh time to exhaust
your cardio yeah because you're not
worrying about carrying it out right but
you're not saving something yeah right
like a six-round fight like if you look
at amateurs three-round fights they're
going [ __ ] crazy yeah you know so i
would love to see it we'll see what
happens though
you